c'était leur dernière cartouche les sept
candidats à la primaire de la gauche ont
débattu pour la dernière fois ce jeudi
soir avant le premier tour qui se
tiendra à lui dimanche un débat
articulée notamment autour de la
sécurité sociale de la justice ou encore
du revenu universel une proposition
phare de benoît hamon le député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines
lui qui sera forcément attentif à son
score dans son fief électoral
écoutez le au micro de nicolas landry
mais je le regarde avec attention
j'espère que je serai en tête dans la
11e j'espère oui je sais c'est pas du
tout acquis d'avancé 1 mais eh bien moi
je regarderai ça avec intérêt
je vais voir g6 si le monsieur fourgous
fait voter contre moi et là encore
s'amuser mais comme de la donner un euro
parti socialiste je pense que ce sera
trop pour lui pour moi je suis pour
l'instant que l'élection présidentielle
viendra le temps de deux législatives et
si si je ne suis pas élu prête à la
république et mai
du coup on en parlera à ce moment là le
juge toutes les indications seront
évidemment bonne à prendre mais tout ça
n'est pas beaucoup de surprises avec
jean-michel choses non ce sera ouhlala
benoît hamon c'est horrible ils déposent
de l'argent ou benoît hamon c'est le
passé bon et dimanche pour le premier
tour de cette primaire de la gauche
benoît hamon se reposer à six autres
candidats que vous voyez à l'écran
vincent peillon
sylvia pinel arnaud montebourg manuel
valls jean luc bennahmias et françois de
rugy et pour savoir où voter dimanche
entre 9h et 19h vous pouvez consulter le
site www.lesprimairescitoyennes.fr jeu